messieurs bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france pour analyser la situation
au liban déjà palpable depuis deux jours
la tension est montée d'un cran
aujourd'hui je le disais c'est la
première fois depuis la guerre de
juillet 2006 que ce bonnart tirent des
roquettes contre israël
une action qui fait suite au premier
raid israélien est la veille contre le
liban depuis 2014 donc c'est une
première un petit peu pour beaucoup de
choses
est-ce que selon vous jamais l'eau hakim
je commence avec vous la situation peut
se tendre davantage faut-il craindre une
guerre ou est ce un jeu du chat et de la
souris
non je ne crois pas je ne pense pas
qu'il y aura une escalade de la tension
entre le liban et israël
car ce n'est pas dans l'intérêt des
israéliens ou des libanais l'élise rien
ne peut pas garantir une victoire contre
la résistance libanaise
surtout que le hezbollah a pu accroître
sa puissance militaire depuis 2006 en
même temps le fils bouna elle n'a pas
d'intérêt d'entrer dans une guerre
majeure contre parce que il est impliqué
dans la guerre syrienne et en même temps
et là il est face à une crise nationale
grave au liban alors j'ai rêvé spirent
est ce que vous vous êtes du même avis
que jamais loi qui met ce que les deux
protagonistes ne sont finalement pas
disposé à une confrontation militaire
qui est derrière le hezbollah c'est la
première question qu'il faut se poser
bien sûr le hezbollah a été créé à
partir de 1982 1 par le pouvoir à
téhéran n'est ce pas donc si vous
rejoignez les opérations en cours de
tirs de roquettes depuis le liban
les tirs de roquettes une très nombreux
plus de 4000 depuis la bande de gaza par
le hamas soutenus par téhéran
mais si vous rejoignez à cela un an que
les opérations anti israéliennes sur les
tankers ou autres bateaux dans le
halff vous voyez donc une réponse de
téhéran
très coordonnée très limité je suis
d'accord avec notre interlocuteur depuis
beyrouth sur le côté très contrôlée des
opérations mais c'est une réponse
globale de teyran à l'action globale
d'israël sur un certain nombre
d'opérations contre les intérêts
iraniens
jamais le requiem est ce que vous êtes
d'accord est ce que vous pensez que
c'est l'iran qui est derrière ces tirs
de roquettes
aujourd'hui au liban non je ne crois pas
parce qu avec tous mes respects pour
l'opinion de votre invité le facebook a
été une des factions de la résistance
libanaise qui a qui ont surgi en réponse
aux attaques israéliennes
tout d'abord c'est un parti libanais
malgré qu'ils aient supporté par
thériault par les eaux alors le
dynamisme et qui fait que tu pourras
repères et ils opèrent dans un contexte
tout à fait libanais nationale
confessionnelles bien sûr comme la la
structure du pays
ce n'est pas lui qui a instauré cette
structure confessionnelle dans le pays
alors comment opèrent selon ses intérêts
et selon cette décision je crois pas
qu'il y a un lien alors que ce qui s'est
passé au sud liban avec ce qui s'est
passé autant que rien dans la merde aux
mains j' avais je reviens vers vous est
ce que ce serait une manière pour israël
de déstabiliser la région c'est que
l'état hébreu a tout de même de nombreux
intérêts dans la région qui reçoit les
requêtes
n'est ce pas c'est israël qui te reçoit
les requêtes soit du hamas soit du
hezbollah dont il est difficile de
déstabiliser une région
quand vous êtes vous même la cible des
attaques n'est ce pas je pense qu'il
faut voir les choses justes à dans le
sens opposé et je crois qu'il ya un plan
global à d'israël pour effectivement
évité un iran nucléaire
et cela c'est de
puis plus d'une dizaine d'années qui est
en place et de l'autre côté
eh bien vous avez les réactions de
téhéran pour dire eh bien nous ne
laisserons pas faire et c'est la lecture
fondamental de cette situation le
hezbollah a été financée créé depuis
1982 1 par téhéran
le premier secrétaire général fait de la
halle a été nommé par terran et on lui a
demandé
on lui a dit maintenant la
responsabilité que tu exerces n'est pas
vis-à-vis du pouvoir libanais mais tu es
responsable de vente et rend jamais loi
qui mettrait rapidement juste pour
clôturer le sujet et rend puisqu'on
parle du divan ici est ce que pour vous
c'est une manière pour israël de
déstabiliser la région est ce que c'est
ce que l'état hébreu cherche et après on
passera au liban la dernière agression
initiée par israël c'était une tentative
par le premier ministre nouveau premier
ministre israélien qui a compté de
changer les règles d'engagement avec le
hezbollah
d'autant qu'il reprochait à son
prédécesseur de ne pas adopter pour
l'éthique plus violente avec la
résistance libanaise
mais comme il était confronté par une
position ferme parle justement les et
liens non plus répondu ce qui indique
une réticence à l'escala et l'échec du
premier ministre israélien de changer
les règles du jeu quand on convoque
invités dit que duarte payé par terrain
et qu'il est financé et qui
départageront ont dit la même chose
d'irréel dans notre région quel été créé
par les britanniques
et puis adoptée par les états unis
financé et bien militarisé armés par les
états unis contre les pays arabes
alors si on peut on peut utiliser le
même rhétorique bessin ne sont pas aidés
à justifier ou bien
qu'on va retourner sur le liban
notamment sur 7 sur ses tirs entre le
liban et israël le président a condamné
une agression flagrante et dangereuse de
la résolution internationale de 1701 une
plainte a été déposée auprès des nations
unies
l'afer est donc prise très au sérieux
notamment à cause du cadre unique selon
vous j'ai un vestiaire quelle mesure
l'onu peut-elle prendre dans ce cas
précis il ya déjà une présence de l'onu
n'est ce pas dans au sud liban a donc
mais encore une fois il faut revenir au
point de départ qui a lancé les
premières requêtes va ce n'est pas
israël qui cherchent à déstabiliser la
région puisque c'est israël qui reçoit
les requêtes
donc je crois qu'il faut la géopolitique
c'est vraiment l'analyse des fêtes
l'analyse du planning des fêtes
l'analyse du timing et à ce moment là on
peut reconstruire un avis avoir une
position avoir un déclic tarde donc si
vous décrypter les fêtes et bien c'est
ce qu'ils reçoivent les requêtes qui ont
à se plaindre et je pense que la
présence déjà de l'onu au sud liban est
nécessaire pour revenir à une situation
d'accalmie
mais cela dépend aussi des décisions et
c'est très clair a depuis terence hill
vol ainsi téhéran veut accélérer la
crise est bien lire à d'autres requêtes
si c'est simplement un signal d' alerte
et bien on s'arrêtera là
gemalto estime qu'elle la mesure l'onu
peut-elle prendre dans ce cas peut-elle
réellement intervenir même si on sait
qu'il y a la finul qui est présente dans
le sud du liban
je ne vois que l'onu et l'ue peut faire
des comptes sains pour ne pas s quelle
est la situation et jusqu'à maintenant
elle a réussi à faire réaliser cet
objectif
alors je peux voir qu'il n'y aurait pas
une escalade de la tension et je crois
que
les deux parties ont respecté les règles
du jeu qui était instaurée après 2006 le
pays du cèdre traverse actuellement une
crise sans précédent vous le savez crise
économique sociale financière
s'il y avait une guerre est ce que le
pays se relèvera et qu'elle serait lé
les les mesures internationales qui
pourraient être prises j'ai un vestiaire
pour sauver le liban jument l'aider à se
relever vous avez oublié le volet
politique
il ya aussi une prise profondément
politique donc à partir du moment où il
ya une crise politique je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait une guerre parce que vous ne
pouvez pas lancer une opération
militaire si vous n'avez pas un pays
organisé d'un point de vue politique
donc
à cela s'ajoute que vous l'avez souligné
la situation et économique et la
situation sociale donc je crois que le
liban n'est à une priorité vraiment
exceptionnel qui est de s'occuper d'eux
sauce sort et de son avenir à très court
terme et la solution n'est certainement
pas un regardant à l'extérieur en
regardant au sud en regardant vers
israël la priorité du liban c'est de
résoudre la crise libanaise
mais la priorité c'est de former un
gouvernement justement et jamal wakim
est-ce que quelles seraient les mesures
à prendre et ce que le pays traverse une
situation qui est extrêmement grave avec
peut-être imaginons une guerre qui
pourrait déclencher ce qu'on n'espère
pas bien évidemment quelles mesures
internationales pourraient être prises
puisqu'il ya une crise de politique
également au liban je ne crois pas que
la communauté internationale peut
intervenir au liban ont mis à part une
unanimité position entre les puissances
internationales
on a d'une part les états unis loridon
et de l'autre par la russie qui a accru
son influence et son rôle dans
le proche orient avec l'iran et la chine
alors en compte pas sur la communauté
internationale en même temps la classe
politique au liban et la classe
économique
dommage elle est discréditée
on a besoin d'une restructuration du
pays de la classe politique du système
économique
alors et on n'a pas des partis
politiques qui peuvent poser comme
alternative à cette classe politique
dominant alors on va attendre jusqu'à ce
qu'ils peuvent résoudre leurs problèmes
entre eux mais la situation économique
et politique et le vestiaire les tirs de
roquettes ont principalement touché une
région qui est disputé par les deux
parties par les deux pays
ce sont les fermes de chébaa est-ce que
vous pensez que les tirs entre ces deux
pays notamment c'est que recevrait le
liban peuvent aller plus loin je ne
crois pas je crois que on l'a bien vu au
cours de cet entretien à ce sont un
ensemble d'opérations très contrôlé à
très contrôlés dans le golfe est très
contrôlée avec le hamas
très contrôlée avec le hezbollah a donc
parce qu'il n'y a un un centre de
commandement central n'est ce pas il ya
un centre commandement central qui était
téhéran donc il y a à une précision dans
ses opérations
il ya très très peu de deux morts de
dégâts collatéraux
malgré l'ampleur des moyens militaires
classiques et on reste avec
l'utilisation milices on reste avec
l'utilisation d'armement donc
conventionnelle et je ne crois pas qu'il
y ait de possibilité d' escaladeront on
devrait avoir à un retour à l'accalmie
et cela permet au hezbollah de dire nous
existons toujours malgré que le
hezbollah qui n'a pas vraiment intérêt à
défendre en syrie soit jusqu'à la
frontière
avec l'irak donc voilà il y à une prise
de conscience qu'il y a une position de
fermeté à avoir mais ça devrait pas
aller au delà
jamal loyer mais ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec monsieur l'espère oui je
suis d'accord que les cibles qui était
choisie était bien choisi pour une part
causé des dégâts
alors c'est aider des attaques qui
contenait des messages politiques plutôt
que des attaques qui avaient des
objectifs militaires
bien conçu alors je ne crois pas qu'il y
aurait une escalade de la situation et
j'espère bien qu'il n'y aurait pas une
gueule messieurs merci d'avoir été avec
nous j'ai un vestiaire je rappelle que
vous êtes fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté et jamal huaqing
professeur d'histoire contemporaine et
de relations internationales à
l'université libanaise merci à vous pour
ce débat intéressant